schon angefangen. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie am unteren Schenkel und Fuß Schmerzen haben, oder?
Ja, seit einem Tag, seit gestern. Okay, können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben,
stechen, dumpfend. Das ist so wie ein starker Druckschmerz, als ob jemand einen Gürtel um den
Unterschenkel schnürt. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmelze? Wo werden Sie ein Ordnen auf
einer Schmerz schmerzen? Schauen Sie mal, null ist kein Schmerz, zehn ist wirklich unertagbare Schmerzen.
Acht. Können Sie aushalten bis zum Ende des Gesprächs oder möchten Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Herr Lohenstein. Ich habe schon Schmerzmittel probiert, aber das hat nicht geholfen. Deswegen
bin ich jetzt auch gekommen zu Ihnen. Aber ich kann es noch aushalten. Das dauert,
geht nicht so lange. Okay, wir sind gleich. Was haben Sie da dagegen eingenommen?
Ich habe Paracetamol genommen gestern Abend und heute Morgen noch mal eine Ebu-Profene,
aber das hat nicht viel verändert. Ja, okay, verstehe. Herr Lohenstein,
haben Sie irgendwelche Farbeveränderungen auf der Schmerzpunkt bemerkt, wie Rötung oder Bläulich?
Ich habe den Eindruck, das Bein ist irgendwie etwas so heller, ein bisschen heller, fast.
Und auch ziemlich kühl. Ziemlich kühl, haben Sie gesagt, oder? Ja, okay, verstehe. Und
strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus? Herr Lohenstein? Nein, die sind da im Leer und im Fuß.
Ausstrahlen tun sie eigentlich nicht. Also da unten sind die hauptsächlich. Unterhalb des
Knies beginnen die links bis vorne in die Zehenspitzen. Okay, auf welche Seite haben Sie gesagt,
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht notizieren. Linke Seite. Linke Seite, ja, okay, danke.
Herr Lohenstein, haben Sie irgendwelche Auslöser für diese Schmerzen bemerkt?
Ja, also ich hatte diese Schmerzen schon seit ein paar Wochen beim Gehen. Wenn ich gehe,
zu nach 50 Metern, fängt der Fuß an, zu schmerzen das Bein und dann bin ich stehengeblieben,
habe gewartet, dann konnte ich wieder weitergehen. Aber jetzt geht es gar nicht mehr.
Jetzt kann ich gar nicht mehr groß gehen. Das tut so gut. Okay, verstehe. Sie können nicht lange
durch die Strecke laufen. Also zuletzt höchstens so 50 Meter. Ja, okay, verstehe. Haben Sie irgendwelche
Missempfindungen wie Griebend, Hauptpreizgefühlt auf der Schmerzpunkte oder?
So ein bisschen, so ein Kribbeln. So ein Kribbeln ist dabei und auch so ein bisschen, ja, vielleicht
aus ein bisschen Kraftlos. Aber Hauptsache, es ist ein starker Druckschmerz. Sind die Schmerzen
lagerabhängig? Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie Ihre Beine hochgelagen, verliehen denn die Schmerzen oder
haben Sie eine große Unterschiede gemerkt? Ja, ich habe seit 15 Jahren ungefähr hohen
Blutdruck. Ja, nehmen Sie, was dagegen? Ein Ja, Medikament, Moment, das heißt,
Candesatan ist das und vorher hatte ich ein anderes, da kriegte ich aber Husten von und dann hat der
Arzt das umgestellt, jetzt nehme ich Candesatan, 8 Milligramm, morgens eine ganze und abends eine halbe
und dann nehme ich auch noch etwas gegen hohe Harnsäure, ich hatte schon mal einen Gichtanfälle in den
Flüßen, das nehme ich, nehmen Sie dagegen? Alloporinol, 300, eine Tablette morgens, das nehme ich seit 10
Jahren. Seit wann haben Sie diese Gicht? Ungefähr 10, 12 Jahre, ja, da begann das und seitdem
nehme ich auch jetzt diese Tabletten und ich hatte danach noch einmal einen Gichtanfall, da hatte ich
die Tabletten abgesetzt, aber inzwischen, seitdem ich sie jetzt regelmäßig nehme, habe ich keinen
Gichtanfall mehr gehabt. Okay, wann haben Sie letztes Mal Gichtanfall? Das war so circa 6, 7 Jahre.
Okay, diese Beschwerden ähnlich wie Gichtanfall oder gibt es Unterschied? Nee, das ist anders, beim
Gichtanfall war das Gelenk der große C ganz warm und rot. Ja, das meinte ich so. Das ist jetzt nicht
so, das ist ganz anders. Jetzt gibt es keine Schwellung, oder? Nee, das ist auch nicht warm.
Ja, kühl. Ja, kühl. Ja, verstehe ich genau. Okay. Und haben Sie noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen
ausgeladen? Zucker, Zucker habe ich noch seit 5 Jahren ungefähr, da nehme ich Haupttabletten ein.
Metformin, Metformin 850, eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends. Okay, gut. Ist Ihre
Bulletsuckerwerte in Ordnung? Ja, ich gehe schon mehr oder weniger regelmäßig zum Hausarzt,
lasst das kontrollieren und der war eigentlich zuletzt ganz zufrieden, aber er sagt, ich
bin viel zu schwer, ich muss abnehmen. Aber das ist nicht so einfach. Ja, verstehe. Und haben Sie Ihre
Bulletsuckerwerte gemessen, Lasten bei der Kontrolle? Blutfett oder Blutzucker? Beides.
Was meinst du? Sie haben schon die genotenen? Die Blutfette sind auch zu hoch. Da nehme ich
auch ein Medikamentverein. Das ist aber schon länger, das nehme ich fast schon 20 Jahre,
Medikamente. Zuletzt nehme ich jetzt eins, das vertrage ich gut, das heißt,
Rosovastatin, da steht 10 hinter, die Stärke, dann nehme ich Rosovastatin, eine Tablette abends.
Wie viele Milligrammen? 10 Milligramm. Das war es, oder? Ja, das war das, was ich
an Medikament nehme und was ich auch kann. Okay, gut. Herr Loewenstein, sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ja, Tätanusimpfung habe ich, dann habe ich gegen Corona, bin ich dreimal geimpft bisher.
Ja, der Hausarzt sagt, also die Impfungen sind in Ordnung, habe mich auch jetzt gegen
Grippe impfen lassen. Ja, okay, gut. Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente außer diese
Medikamente regelmäßig ein? Nur die, die ich jetzt Ihnen genannt habe. Die Medikamente,
die ich Ihnen genannt habe. Wo denn Sie schon mal operiert, Herr Loewenstein?
Als Kind, da war ich so circa acht Jahre alt, da wurde ich am Blindarm operiert und mit 12 Jahren an den
Mandeln und vor circa, war das sechs Jahren, da war ich also 55, da wurde ich an der Bandscheibe
operiert wegen einem Bandscheibenvorfall. Ja, Bandscheibenvorfall. Wo war das Bandscheibenvorfall?
Servikale oder ländenbibelsäule? Ändern Sie sich daran? Was heißt Servikale? Ja, ich meine im Nackenbereich.
Hast du? Nee, das war unten im Röbken, ländenbibelsäule, das war auch links. Und das waren Schmerzen,
die streiten auch so in den Unterschenkel, in den Fuß ein. Das war manchmal so ähnlich wie jetzt der
Schmerz, aber jetzt ist der Schmerz stärker. Ja, verstehe. Okay, Herr Loewenstein, brauchen Sie? Ja,
ich brauche ziemlich lange schon und ziemlich viel. Ich brauche eine Schachtelzirka am Backt
und das Ganze jetzt seit 45 Jahren. 45 Jahre. Ja, verstehe. Und dünken Sie Alkohol auch? Ja,
ich trinke abends schon zwei Flaschen Bier, so 0,5. Also die trinke ich schon jeden Abend. Meine
Frau sagt immer, dass Bier ist auch nicht gut für den Zucker und für den Blutdruck. Und auch,
wie geht es an Fall? Aber es schmeckt so gut. Ja, das richtig, genau. Okay. Herr Loewenstein,
haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien? Nein, ich habe keine Allergien. Entschuldigung,
Herr Loewenstein, diese Bandscheibe Vorfalloperation, haben es zu irgendwelchen
Komplikationen oder war alles in Ordnung bei der OP? Nein, das ist ganz gut verlaufen. Ich habe
dann eine Reha-Maßnahme gemacht und konnte dann auch nach drei, vier Monaten wieder arbeiten in
meinem Beruf. Ja, ja. Was machen Sie beruflich? Ich bin Elektriker. Okay. Herr Loewenstein,
schlafen Sie gut, schlafen Sie ausreichend? Ja, ich schlafe, ich schlafe ganz gut. Meine
Frau sagt zwar, ich schnarche so laut, aber schnarchen, schnarchen durch, aber irgendwie sagte sie,
sollte ich das mal untersuchen lassen, aber das habe ich bisher noch nicht gemacht. Aber ich
fühle mich eigentlich tagsüber ganz gut, fühle mich morgens ausgeruht.
Haben Sie keine Einnickungen?
Müssen Sie tagsüber kurze Schlafpause machen oder? Braue ich.
Ich konnte Akustik nicht verstanden. Ich brauche einen, ich kann tagsüber ohne,
komme ich ohne Schlaf, ohne Mittagsschlaf ausgeht. Okay, ja gut.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Programme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, beim Stuhlgang, da ist es manchmal verstopft. Das geht dann nur manchmal alle zwei Tage.
Das ist so ein bisschen mühevoll und dann trinke ich etwas Flaumensaft und Traubensaft und dann
geht das besser. Aber nehmen Sie keine Medikamente? Nein, nehmen keine Medikamente und
Wasserlassen. Ja, nachts muss ich zweimal Wasserlassen. Ich war schon mal beim Urologen und
er sagt, ja, die Postata ist etwas vergrößert und er rät mir auch zu einem Medikament,
aber das habe ich noch nicht genommen, weil ich nehme schon so viele Medikamente ein und
deswegen will ich das erst mal ohne probieren. Zwei mal nachts gehen Sie auf die Toilette.
Herr Nürnstein, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie verheiratet sind. Ob ich richtig verstanden habe.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 36 und 34 Jahre alt. Ja, die sind beide auch etwas
übergewichtig schon. Mein Arzt sagt, das liegt etwas in der Familie. Aber gut, die leben aber
inzwischen bei uns nicht mehr zu Hause, sondern haben ihre eigenen Familien. Wahrscheinlich kochen Sie
auch gerne, oder? Ich koche nicht gerne, aber meine Frau ist gerne. Ja, super, das geht nicht auch so.
Okay, Herr Nürnstein. Und sind Ihre, leben Ihre Eltern noch? Ja, der Vater, der ist mit 79 Jahren an
einem Herzinfarkt verstorben. Die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 86 jetzt und hat Rheuma und auch etwas
Alterszucker. Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist zwei Jahre älter als ich, also 63 Jahre alt. Der hatte
vor zwei Jahren einen Schlaganfall. Herr Nürnstein, Ihr habt alle wichtige Frage von meiner Seite
schon gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder ergänzen? Ja, was kann das sein, diese
Stahlmärz da im Bein? Das wäre schon etwas Angst. Ja, Herr Nürnstein, natürlich habe ich eine
Verdacht, ja nur eine Vermutung, aber zuerst musste ich Sie ausführlich verpädlich untersuchen und
ein paar Lobbe untersuchen gehen. Und nachher werde ich ausführlich erklären, aber ich denke,
Sie haben eine Schaufensterkrankheit. Ein Nachbar mir mal erzählt, der hat gemeint,
als ich nicht so gut gehen konnte, sagt er, du hast bestimmt die Schaufensterkrankheit.
Ja, das ist wichtig, aber nicht schlimm jetzt. Wir können nach ein paar kleine Eingeriffen
dieses Problem lösen. Okay, gut. Dann machen wir jetzt erst die Untersuchung und dann gucken wir.
Ja, genau. Sie dürfen jetzt den Platz nehmen im Wartezimmer und werde ich gleich bei Ihnen. Okay,
danke. Haben Kollegen andere Fragen? Können wir erst als Gespräche anfangen, Mehmet?
Ja, wir können färschen. Ja, okay. Dann starten wir. Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Abend. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich, ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, habe ich. Okay, danke. Ein 61-jähriger Patient, Richard Löhnenstein, hat sich heute bei uns
wegen seit einem Tag bestehende Druckende Schmerzen am linken Wadepfad und linken Hallus
vorgestellt. Der Patient berichtet, dass in den Schmerzpunkten kalt und ein bisschen bläss.
Blass, ja, ja, blass, kalt und blass. Und der Patientin berichtete, dass er mehr als 50 Meter
nicht laufen könne und die Frage nach Parästhesien und Lehmungen wurden verneint. Die Schmerzen
legen bei acht auf der Schmerzskala und dagegen nehmen der Patient Evo Profen und Paracetamol,
aber ihm nicht ganz geholfen. Also Paracetamol und Evo Profen waren bisher ohne Wirkung, ohne
ausreichende Wirkung. Ja, ohne Wirkung, ja, genau. Und der Patient habe keine ÖDM ab der
Schmerzpunkt bemerkt. Entschuldigung, ich habe nichts gesagt. Okay. Und der Patient hat
keinen Schlafproblem. Manchmal habe er eine Abnöhe, aber die waren nicht so wichtig für
ihr. Und manchmal habe er Robstepatzion und dagegen nehmen er keinen Medikamenten. Hat der Patient
eine Tagesmütigkeit? Mütigkeit habe ich nicht gefragt, Entschuldigung, aber ich kann nachher
wieder erneut fragen. Das haben Sie mich gefragt in der Hand am Nese, ob ich tagsüber einschlafen
oder ja, ja, ja, Entschuldigung, ich habe falsch verstanden. Entschuldigung, ja, er hat kein
Problem tagsüber. Genau. Und Patient Risikofaktoren? Hat der Patient Risikofaktoren? Ja, genau.
Er rauche seit 45 Jahren 20 Päckiges und abends trinke er zwei Flächen mehr und er ist adipös.
Ja, deswegen hat er Risikofaktoren gegen Schlafabnöhe. Und Antwort an Entschuldigung. Es besteht
ein erhebliches, cardio-vaskuläres Risikoprofil bei den Patienten. Übergewicht, Nikotinabusos,
Hypercholesterinämie, Hyperlipämie, Hypertonie, ja, als auch schwere Gefäß-Risikofaktor.
An Vorerkrankungen leide er an arterielle Hypertonie, dagegen nehme er Kandesatren,
acht Milligramm Ogens und vier Milligramm Abends und er leide auch an Gisteranfall,
dagegen nehme er Allopurinol, seit zehn bis zwölf Jahren und leide er, leide er
an einer Diabetes-Militrostypt II, dagegen nehme er Metformin, achthundundfünfzig Milligramm Ogens
und abends und gegen Hyperlipidämie, nehme er Rosovastatin, zehn Milligramm abends, seit zwanzig Jahren.
Die geklachten Beschwerden von den Patienten, die ihn jetzt akut in die Aufnahme und Ambulanz führen,
wie lange hat der Patient diesbezüglich schon Beschwerden geäußert, bezüglich dieser Beschwerden?
Ja, er hat gesagt, seit ein paar Wochen diese Beschwerden haben.
Ja, seit ein paar Wochen hat er eine Limitierung der freien Gestreckungen,
auf zuletzt 50 bis 50 Meter und jetzt gestern eben einen schweren Ruheschmerz.
Gut.
Und das familiäre Risikofaktoren?
Entschuldigung, könnt ihr das jetzt noch?
Ja, ich habe auch familiäre Risikofaktoren.
Seine Mutter habe Diabetes-Militrost und sein Vater ist an Myocardinfarkt verstorben
und sein Bruder habe Schlaganfall.
Die sind auch Risikofaktoren für die Patienten.
Und ein Bruder hatte vor zwei Jahren einen apoplektischen Inselt?
Ja, genau.
Ja?
Okay.
Gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Bevor ich meine Verdachtstiagnose sagen, so setzlich würde ich noch etwas sagen.
Der Patient habe Nüktorie.
Deswegen war er bei ihrem Hausarzt gewesen
und seinem Hausarzt hat gesagt, es kann ein Prostataverkurs sein.
Ich wollte ein Medikament verschreiben, aber der Patient wollte nicht einnehmen.
Okay.
Die ananöstischen Angaben beuten am ersten auf eine PRVK, perferliche Atelgelder Verschlusskrankheit.
Ja.
Als differenzial Diagnose kommen PRVT, kann auch sein.
Und habe auch er wurde vor sechs Jahren wegen Discos Prolapsus operiert.
Deswegen kann es eine Komplikation von dieser Bandscheibenvorfall sein.
Diese Bandscheibenoperation, wissen Sie, in welchem Segment die Stadt fand?
Lenden, wer der Säule hat, hat der Patient gesagt.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau, welche Discos-Seite.
Auch die linke Seite.
Also der Verdacht auf einer bei der klinischen Bild Claudicatio Intermittent,
jetzt Verdacht auf einen Verschluss eines Gefäßes, lässt schon eine PRVK denken.
Differenzial Diagnosis, nostisch vielleicht nicht ganz typisch Radikulitis.
Muss man in Betracht ziehen und die Voroperation erwähnt.
Auch die kann eine Rolle spielen, aber im Augenblick spricht doch eher alles bei dem Risikoprofil des Patienten.
Und er hat ja ein metabolisches Syndrom, klassischer Art.
Hypertomizucker, Hyperlipidämie, Cholesterinämie, Hyperurikämie, Adipositas, Nikotinabusus.
Es kommen eigentlich alle Risikofaktoren.
Das spricht schon doch in einem hohen Maße für eine Gefäßerkrankung.
Da müssen wir dementsprechend eine Diagnostik machen.
Und die körperliche Untersuchung denke ich wird, dass auch schon weitgehend erhärten diese Verdachtstiagnose.
Okay, ja, ich finde, das haben Sie sehr systematisch in der Anamnese erhoben.
Und haben sich auch nicht durch meine Gegen- oder Zwischenfragen aus der Ruhe bringen lassen.
Versuchen Sie, möglichst viele, Sie haben das gemacht, aber möglichst viele Patientenbegriffe in die Fachsprache zu überführen.
Der Bruder hatte einen Schlaganfall, ja, das ist richtig, aber es sollte vielleicht ein Apoplex sein bei der Schilderung beim Oberarzt.
Da Sie da bitte dran denken.
Und im Anfang haben Sie auch, wie das viele machen, ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch machen,
werden die Hand vor den Mund genommen, an den Mund, nachher haben Sie das überhaupt nicht mehr gemacht, jetzt gerade eben auch wieder.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm, nur daran denken, möglichst viel die Hand den Mund verbergen.
Weil das ist dann von der Sprache her schwieriger, einfach das vielleicht zu verstehen.
Aber ich sehe übermorgen, wenn Sie die Prüfung haben, bin ich sehr optimistisch, dass Sie diese Prüfung in Stuttgart gut überstehen.
Vielen Dank.
Ihr hatte Schwierigkeiten wegen meiner Verbindung, das war ein Nachteil für mich, wie jetzt.
Ja, also Sie konnten mich schlecht verstehen?
Ja, wegen meiner Verbindung ein paar Mal konnte ich nicht gut verstehen, aber das habe ich schon geschadet.
Ob es an meiner Verbindung hier liegt, da müsste ich den Moderator fragen.